my issue with the new atheism is that it
was in many ways it was about mocking
religious people it was about mocking
these stupid rednecks and chavs who and
Irish Catholics which is my background
who believe in God you know uneducated
ignorant people
um and it was about basically saying
that the idea that humankind is special
that we were designed that we are above
everything else is a ridiculous idea and
what I want to do is find a humanistic
way to make the same argument I want to
find because I don't believe in God and
I am not a religious person even though
I was brought up religiously what I'm
interested in is finding a a post god
humanistic way to say yes humankind is a
superior species we are different to
every other living creature on this
planet there is something special about
us there is something wondrous about us
it's like I want to defend the idea of
wonder that the mystery of how human
beings are so incredibly intelligent and
morally inclined so the question then
becomes do you need God to do that or
can can you do that in a postcard
environment and I think that's the
struggle lots of us are facing that's
why I brought up the question because
when I was John Peterson handed me on
his podcast he grilled me about this for
three hours and we went around and
around I wrote a piece on my sub stack
recently called the atheism delusion I
don't know if you saw that
um so I'm thinking about this quite a
lot now and it's
my answer on a pragmatic level forget
the philosophical level and pragmatic
level is this we we have a society in
which many many people are not religious
and they also require the same things
that we all require which is meaning and
purpose a sense of right and wrong a
sense of what's true and false a a kind
of orientation towards uh having some
kind of investment in the society that
they live in and an orientation towards
seeing it prosper and grow into the
future
um
and to the extent that that can be
achieved without religion someone like
me who's agnostic and someone like you
doesn't believe in God uh we can I'm
sure totally get behind that the problem
is I do start to wonder my issue with
the new atheism is that once you've
taken God off the pedestal and you've
put the Superior in your words human
being on it who gets to decide what's
true
right because uh I can I can pull out a
scientific study that shows
transitioning is helpful to children at
this and you know do you see what I'm
saying yeah right so once truth is once
there's nothing that's kind of above us
that we all take for granted that's
passed down to us that is outside of us
yeah it's very difficult to then have
people who differ politically agree on a
certain set of values that are just
embedded in society
yeah I get that I I my argument would be
that the only way to understand truth or
arrive at truth is through freedom I
know that might sound facetious but I I
think that's very a very real Prospect
and something that people should
consider uh you know I think
um it's people have been talking for a
long time about the god-shaped whole in
modern society what do we do after God
uh how do we Define what is right and
wrong do the Ten Commandments matter
anymore in the absence of God
um so these are very real questions and
very real issues that people are talking
about and concerned about but I think
um the the point I would make is that
in my view and I know this probably is
offensive to religious people
all of those values all of those kind of
God delivered ideas that people
generally agreed on and and still do to
a certain extent
um they're really they really came from
man they really were written by man I
don't believe that there is a God I
don't believe that God did give tablets
to Moses or hide in the bush and talk to
Jesus Christ or anything like that I
don't believe that happened so these are
the creations of man in a very positive
way and we know that there is a close
link between Christianity and the
Enlightenment and between the religious
struggle for freedom of conscience and
the right to express oneself and the
right to believe what one wants to
believe and then the subsequent
development of Enlightenment values the
freedom of conscience freedom of speech
the freedom to think how you want to
think so um I'm not someone who poo-poos
religion I was brought up religiously I
was brought up as a Roman Catholic I was
an altar boy I went to Catholic schools
from the ages of 4 to 18
um I benefited from them enormously I
was educated by nuns in a school that
was built around the bottom of this
convent on top of a hill so it was great
it was wonderful and it it benefited me
enormously but I do think that there has
to be a way in which society precisely
through exercising its freedom to think
and it's freedom to argue and its
freedom to dissent can arrive at
something that we can generally agree to
be true